good evening I'm Maryann Brownlow
welcome to borders this past week
probably like many of you I had my
income tax done and afterwards like most
years I I felt like committing seppuku
in front of the IRS and then I perused
the cheating of America and I felt like
Sebek who was possibly too mild a
response we're very pleased this evening
to have as our guest Charles Lewis and
Bill Allison they are here to discuss
their new book the cheating of America
how tax avoidance and evasion by the
super-rich are costing the country
billions and what you can do about it
that pretty well sums up the book but I
will say it is an incisive expose that
fingers the fat cats and the permissive
system that allows for their
indiscretions Charles Lewis is the
founder and executive director of the
Center for Public Integrity which is a
nonpartisan nonprofit that focuses on
ethics and public service issues prior
to that he was an investigative reporter
for ABC and CBS News and a producer for
60 minutes bill Allison is a former
researcher for the Philadelphia Inquirer
and he is the senior editor at the
Center for Public Integrity please join
me in welcoming Charles Lewis and Bill
Allison what's a great pleasure to be
here and Marianne thank you this is an
pleasure I thought I would talk a little
bit about the Center for Public
Integrity briefly this was a work that
took three years and a dozen people
digging through US tax court records
which I wouldn't necessarily recommend
for the faint of heart and the idea was
to do what we have done in over a
hundred reports in the last ten years
look at
what's going on in our democracy and
what's really happening and who who
benefits and who doesn't benefit and how
the system works basically and I mean
we've never done anything about taxes we
don't have an agenda about taxes this so
the Center for Public Integrity was
started in 1990 it's a nonpartisan
nonprofit research organization that
does investigative reporting and I'm
proud to announce today that
investigative reporters and editors has
given us the the national award for
online journalism for last year and our
book the buying of the president 2000
has just been named a finalist for best
book in the US which is the fifth
straight year we've had a book as a
finalist so we do investigative reports
and books that a lot of people in
Washington would prefer that we never
write and we're we are nonpartisan we
alienate both parties equally and we
generally investigate and go into
records that people generally don't look
at including journalists and so so
that's the center the thing that most
shocked me about the book in system
general broad strokes first of all I
understood that we would find really
wealthy folks and corporations that
didn't pay taxes I I sort of had a hunch
that that might happen based on our
other work over the years what I was
startled by was how bad a problem it is
there are thousands of individuals and
thousands of corporations that don't pay
any taxes in this country one out of
every six corporations with 250 million
assets or more pay zero taxes every year
in this country we found that the the
biggest shock was not just the number of
people and by the way we name names in
this book we tell you who they are and
what they've been up to this is all
based on records that they would hope
that you never see but we then wanted to
see what's the government doing about
this
what's the IRS doing about this the
Internal Revenue Service well it turns
out not much it we found that the kinder
gentler IRS that that has been created
in light of a lot of hearings and new
laws and an independent commission that
oversees them and things like that in
the last couple years at the same time
over the last decade we have gutted
enforcement by the IRS so what am I
talking about well if you have ten do
more than ten million dollars to the IRS
the IRS will take 10 or 20 years to come
after you if they do at all and on
average they recover 17 cents on the
dollar
folks who have 10 million dollars know
this and they have lawyers and
accountants who help them do it and a
lot of the book is showing how this
works how badly has the IRS been gutted
and you know I'm not expecting anyone to
you know break into tears over the IRS
here no one like cite the IRS or paying
taxes I understand that but the
enforcement staff the IRS has been cut
by one-third prosecutions are down or
1/2 what they were 20 years ago asset
seizures are roughly 1/10 what they were
10 years ago they went from 10,000 to
about 150 roughly it's worse than that
actually it's much much worse and and so
what it means is that the IRS is
outgunned they don't really know how to
deal with this problem
and we had an IRS lawyer who for obvious
reasons asked to be named not have us
mention his name said you know if you go
through thousands and thousands of pages
and your court case takes years and
years and years why do you think we go
after the little guys they can't fight
back
quote-unquote and that's what they do
and so so this is a book about about
folks who haven't have their own set of
laws that they abide by that are
different than most Americans most
Americans if they get a notice about
being audited quake in their boots and
reach for the checkbook
and that they don't want to get in
trouble I mean and you're terrified
basically we had tax scam artists and
accountants and lawyers tell us that
when you hear from the IRS about how
much you owe that's basically just a
recommendation you should take it as the
first offer and a negotiation and that
is how a lot of wealthy folks trying to
avoid and evade taxes handle the tax
issue they have experts who will drag it
out for a period of years knowing that
the longer drags out the less chance
that anyone will come after them in this
book ranges from the legal most of what
the center is written about in the last
ten years has been what I call legal
corruption things that seem like they
ought to be illegal but for some reason
they aren't everyone does tax avoidance
so this time of year to some extent we
don't want to get hosed completely and
we try to claim every deduction and then
there's evasion which is out-and-out
illegal which I'll get to in a minute
and then there's a voyage in' the sort
of the gray area between those two
worlds my personal favorite part of the
book was I don't know how I ended up
with this job but my job was to go
confront the bad guys and of course most
of them wouldn't even you know open
their front door or even let you go see
past their gate large gate I did go to
Bailey's to the jungle Bailey's to
Affeldt to find a fellow who had fled
the country for tax evasion
he had he was a pillar of his community
62 years old a government contractor
with security clearances and he decided
one day after the IRS and the feds found
out that he had been stashing money in
in Mexico he he decided that he didn't
want to serve jail time and he didn't
want to be indicted and so he fled and
he and his third wife 30 years younger
than him fled first to Acapulco then to
Paris then to Greece then to Paraguay
then other parts of South America then
to Vancouver and then they ended up in
Bailey
and there is no extradition treaty with
bailey's he's there for good he's very
happy he has a large house with a
beautiful orange tile roof and a big
sort of palatial estate he has a resort
and so I checked myself into the resort
as a guest I don't think they were happy
to see me necessarily in fact when I
drove up it was a scene of the boys from
Brazil it was raining and the windshield
wipers going and I can barely see where
I'm supposed to drive and the only way
to get to this resort is across the
river and a little boat and behind this
resort is 200 miles of jungle of
Guatemala and I haven't been any of
these places before done I'm completely
out of my element and so I pull into a
parking lot and I see this guy looked
like Jed the Sailor vaguely waving and
and I thought I wonder who that is
and I and I parked the car and just as I
turn he's at the door and it was Joe
Ross whose alias is JP con P I co n and
he said I must be pretty damn important
for you to come halfway around the world
to see me and I said oh you're very
important enough for the next four days
I talked to him for twenty five hours he
would not go on the record but he would
he basically did tell me his life story
and his the headline is he said I won
and he said you know they can't touch me
I've got six or eight law firms on
retainer if anyone's coming near me I'll
know about it I've put all my assets in
two companies I failed to mention there
are three million corporations today
that no one knows who owns them there's
three trillion dollars in assets
offshore the IRS has no idea what to do
about it that's there's a whole subtext
here that's in our book about
globalization the ability of countries
including the u.s. to track the money
that's a whole nother subject but he
gets CNN every day gets the New York
Times flowing in every day he has 25
people waiting on him hand and foot
making $6 a day and including gourmet
cooks and he lives like a king and and
he did win
the question is we opened the book and
I'll turn it over to Bill we open the
book with Leona Helmsley who can forget
Leona Helmsley and the famous comment at
the Dunnellon mansion state up in
Greenwich Connecticut when her head
housekeeper said to her one day you must
pay a lot in taxes and she looked at her
whether the curious look and said pay
taxes we don't pay taxes only the little
people pay taxes so the question is how
many Leona Helmsley's are there out
there how many Mark Rich's are there out
there the only difference between Leona
Helmsley and Mark rich as Leona Helmsley
went to prison that's about the only
difference anyway so this is a book that
names names it tells you who these
people are it tells you how they did
what they did it tells you how the feds
handled it or didn't handle it and so so
anyway if you want to get into that now
I'm afraid that there will be some
people out there that will read this
book and try to avoid paying their taxes
and I realize that that'll be some
people's motive and I suspect that you
probably could learn a few things that
way too I hate to admit it don't tell
anybody so anyway I'll turn things over
to Bill and then we'll do questions
which are always more fun than yammering
away here so thank you I was thinking of
when Chuck was talking about the avoidin
and evasion and avoidance I was it's
very rare to get an IRS employee who's
willing to talk to you they're often
terrified well first of all there's a
rule that they cannot reveal taxpayer
information under penalty of law and
it's kind of the IRS death penalty and
and beyond that they're afraid to talk
to reporters often because they're
afraid that they're going to be accused
of incompetence that you're calling them
to attack them that they're gonna be
caught or jackbooted thugs or this kind
of thing so when you do find the rare
IRS agent who will discuss things with
you off the record usually it's a gold
mine and I was thinking of one instance
when I was talking to somebody who had
been tracking a fairly wealthy real
estate developer for years and years and
had been involved in any number of tax
court battles with him
and this guy actually lived in a
relatively small community and one day
the IRS agent picks up a newspaper from
that local community and turns to a page
and sees a one-page a story about a
7-eleven being held up for you know 50
or 60 bucks and the guy being caught and
there being a weapons charge in the
robbery charge and this was a big to do
in this small town and on the opposite
page is a picture of the real estate
developer opening up a shopping mall and
he's thinking here's a guy on the right
who's evaded millions and millions of
dollars in taxes and he can get away
with it and here's a poor sap on the
left with medley has done something
illegal but he's going to go to jail for
several years and the kind of a
disjunction between the two really
struck the IRS agent as being you know
the classic example of the difference
between what you can get away with and
what you can't in this society and and
the advantages of being well-heeled and
among those advantages is that tax cases
complicated ones are generally
prosecuted in civil court or end up in
civil court not in Criminal Court one of
the reasons is is that when you do have
the kinds of civil fraud or the kinds of
fraud involved in a tax case it's very
difficult to to prove it you have again
the thousands of Records and thousands
of documents the foreign corporations a
20 or 30 step process to go through and
for IRS our agents to track this is and
prove it or the Justice Department to
prove it in a court of law is
exceedingly difficult what jury is going
to want to spend ten years on a case I
mean it's it's the difficulties are
almost insurmountable in some cases or
there's very simple tricks one of the
things in the book that we found and
this is it it always fascinated us how
the variations and the the ingenuity of
avoiders innovators and what they did to
get around certain requirements the IRS
has a place in the tax form where you
have to report if you're the beneficiary
of a foreign trust and one of the ways
around this is to simply list somebody
else as the beneficiary of a foreign
trust we had a Forbes 400 member who had
set up a trust in the Channel Islands
where he did this and named various
charitable institutions schools
hospitals that kind of thing as the
beneficiaries of his offshore trusts and
he was the one who got all the income
from it I mean hundreds of thousands of
dollars each year
so that was a neat trick to get around
reporting requirements in another case a
pair of movie producers who had hit
movies in the 1980s but they made
hundreds of millions of dollars off of
you know the that starred the likes of
Schwarzenegger and Stallone these
gentlemen set up offshore subsidiaries
for their movie company funneled profits
through five or six different companies
offshore eventually all the money wound
up in foreign trusts over offshore the
IRS tracked it for years and years
finally caught up with them and their
argument is well the Trust's are the
ones that are on the income the Trust's
are citizens of foreign countries the
corporations are foreign corporations so
even though these are American movies
that you know all the costs were
associated with America the income is
foreign and we don't know any taxes on
it the the offshore world is you know
the IRS really doesn't have the
resources to go after it and to track
all of these things and another thing
that intrigued us though is how much you
can get away with in the United States
and how the tax code itself is so full
of loopholes and through perfectly legal
means people who have incomes
to cite one example there was a
gentleman who went from being not a
member of the Forbes 400 to being a
member of Forbes 400 and one year he
boosts his assets that much is net worth
he did it by taking out a hundred
million dollar loan from his company to
buy a bank and yet he reported negative
income of two million dollars he didn't
make any money that year he lost money
and yet he wound up on the Forbes 400
where he's remained every cent ever
since and he's worth 1.2 billion dollars
he did it through a very complicated
again series of transactions involving
distressed oil and gas companies in
Oklahoma that have had large cap or
large operating losses for year after
year after year they go bankrupt the IRS
and this is one of the things anytime
anybody tries to close a loophole
there's always another loophole you can
use to get around it with with the net
operating loss as the IRS said no you
can't buy companies just for their net
operating losses which is this huge tax
write-off that you can take up to 15
years however if you are one of the
creditors of the company you can
essentially take over that company
because they owe you the money and then
you can you can realize their net
operating loss as well what this
individual did was he basically bought
the debt he bought out some of the
creditors and took over the debt and
then he was able to continue buying up
these companies and and you know the
write-offs I think he paid ten million
dollars for the company and the
write-off was one hundred and forty
million dollars so I mean it's quite a
bargain it's like a get out of taxes
free card in a Monopoly game and you
know and this is somebody who's buying
up large portions of a state economy and
able to do this we think other examples
of this that we found we found a the 86
Tax Act was supposed to wipe out a lot
of corporate shelters or I'm sorry
individual tax shelters the corporate
shelters were largely left alone a lot
of the individual shelters were wiped
out and some people converted all of
those
losses they had from regular shelters to
to net operating loss shelters or net
operating losses and another thing that
we found which is one of the more
astonishing things I think in 86 when
they we had the terrible shelter problem
at the 86 TaxACT was supposed to take
care of one in one in four hundred
people with incomes over two hundred
thousand dollars paid less than five
percent of their income in taxes in 1996
which was the most recent year the IRS
released statistics for it was one in
two hundred so the the problem was twice
as bad the number of people who can get
away with this filers individuals and
joint returns and we found people who I
mean there was a filing in a tax court
case where one of the one of the IRS
briefs said something to the effect that
yes we've been auditing these taxpayers
for over thirty years this is the last
audit or this is the last time that
we're trying to go after them because I
mean if they had been involved in this
case year after year for 30 odd years
against the same family who owned you
know high-tech telecommunications
company a luxury hotel in Boulder
Colorado drove around in luxury
automobiles with license plates that say
excess on them and vanity plates and and
yet year after year after year ended up
owing no tax liability I mean it was
just amazing how they could get away
with it and it was funny the the few
times that we did get some of these
people on the phone and we would
identify ourselves and say what we're
doing and explain the book and the my
favorite reaction was one person who had
obviously checked us out you know after
he had gotten the initial message and
told me that he resented the fact that
we were Mach breakers calling
so and then you know I think that one of
the things that there's a there's kind
of a sense in the country and we talked
to average tax payers as well we talked
to a woman who self-employed consultant
who you know never made much money in
her life calls the IRS up for help she
had she had to take money out of an IRA
calls him up for help says please tell
me how do i how do I declare this income
I just want to be sure that I'm doing
this right
IRS tip line gives her the wrong
information she goes through a miserable
two-year battle with the IRS at one
point agents threatened to take her
house away I mean this was one of the
things we found about the IRS is is that
I mean they do certain things very very
well other things they don't do so well
among the things they don't do so well
or going after sophisticated taxpayers
and tax avoiders with these complicated
schemes and then the second thing they
don't seem to do very well as relate
well to the public and sometimes they
can really be their own worst enemy I
mean in her experience that really was
only one person who was who was terrible
most people were either uninformed and
couldn't help her and just frustrating
or realize that that this thing had spun
way out of control and tried to get her
the you know the proper counsel or
advice but because of statutes and
different deadlines and different
limitations it would be too late for her
to file such and such type of appeal or
such and such settlement offer and so
for her was very frustrating and then
you have you know the kind of the the
agent who just wants to you know break
people's kneecaps almost and then
threaten and say that you know not only
do you have this tax debt it's going up
every single day and you're gonna owe
more and more money it's funny that the
the the well-heeled taxpayers never seem
to have those kind of experiences with
IRS agents with the heavy-handed people
at least as far as they were willing to
tell us I probably shouldn't generalize
too much that way but
we're getting back to this situation so
you have that kind of person and their
experience with the IRS and then you
have the moderately to well-to-do people
who hear these stories about you know
the wealthy who get away with this and
they turn to the kind of the internet
hucksters and the the people who
promised you pay no income taxes live
tax-free will set up you know you know
there's all kinds of different the rabbi
trust the offshore trust the offshore
bank accounts and there's just a
plethora of sites and thousands and
thousands of people offering these scams
and you know and we one of the stories
we tell in the book is an upper middle
class family that you know with their
own business that decided well maybe
maybe this is for us maybe we shouldn't
be saps anymore maybe we should try out
one of these schemes and it turned out
they fell into the hands of somebody
who's a tax protester who among other
things when they got their first notice
from the IRS after you know they I mean
these were people who would never steal
would never think of not paying a
parking ticket would never been any kind
of trouble at all with the law or with
anything else and felt that taxes maybe
for them should be optional and here are
all these people saying that don't be a
SAP don't pay your taxes you know just
set this up this is perfectly legal this
is perfectly legitimate so they fall
into this trap and they pay these guys
ten thousand dollars just set up these
these trusts for them and then you know
so after years of paying you know you
know in the tens of thousands of dollars
in taxes they pay zero red flag goes up
at the IRS they send a polite you know
notice of deficiency saying that you
know on the basis of this that and the
other thing we think that you probably
owe X amount in taxes they call the
people who had set up the trust for them
who give them advice like if the IRS
sends you a registered letter and you
don't sign for it then the IRS can't
audit you or can't proceed with their
investigation don't answer IRS phone
calls eventually they get word from the
IRS that they're going to be criminally
liable for tax fraud at which point they
got a reliable you know reputable
attorney to represent them and after
paying what they owed you know we're off
the ho
and and I think a little bit wiser about
it and then on the flip side of that you
have people doing the same thing we one
of the stories we tell in the book is
about Merrill Lynch the brokerage firm
and some people they're a very you know
a very intelligent derivatives trade or
marketer or somebody set up complicated
currency hedging transactions that are
not even sure that that after having
read about them and these tax court
transcripts for months and months and
months so I have the vagus understanding
of how they exactly work but he hires a
former IRS employee somebody in the
chief counsel's office who's familiar
with corporate taxes and they sit down
and say gee you know on paper if we do
this and we set this up like this and we
do this and they draw this thing out on
boxes and I kind of imagine them doing
it on a cocktail napkin although I think
they actually they're on computer paper
or on a computer screen but you know if
we'd set this up like this and we market
it to such-and-such corporations ones
with large capital gains we can offset
those capital gains make it look like
they have huge losses and they can get
out of there paying their taxes and and
the question is what is the difference
between them and the Sham operators the
you know the internet guys and of the
two it's it's the guy running the bogus
internet operation you know who
admittedly is guilty of perpetrating a
fraud he's asking for ten thousand
dollars for something that he can't
deliver but in the same way these you
know some of these corporate tax and
they never have to worry about any kind
of criminal liability they never have to
worry it's always handled through
through civil means and and yet the
distinction between the two
we're in both cases you have something
that is is only valid on paper and has
no economic substance under at least
that's what the Tax Court ruled that's
when appellate court ruled and the case
was dead and you know the corporation
pays the the taxes owed and goes merrily
about its business so I think that that
was one of the surprising differences we
found one quick thing I forgot to
mention which I should
said besides the fact that bill was
miraculous in this project along with
the team of folks that are mentioned in
the book and on our website is the size
of the problem and we're talking about
200 billion dollars a year that where we
have losses euphemistically described by
the IRS as the tax cap money they're not
collecting that they ought to be
collecting now that's tax monies from
all income brackets not just the wealthy
but that's two trillion dollars over ten
years which is $1,600 a person which
sounds awfully familiar it's bigger than
the Bush tax cut you know if you would
just to collect our taxes every one we
would pay a lot less in taxes so that
the size of this problem is not a small
issue this is not just a few derelict
folks out there this is a significant
problem and it's getting worse and I
think that that's one of the headlines
that we we got from this thing the other
thing we haven't talked about it I can't
resist mentioning is one of the reasons
we did this project is I was completely
fascinated about the so called Benedict
Arnold billionaires there's a number of
billionaires who decided that in order
to not pay taxes they would renounce
their citizenship and so we had the heir
to the Campbell Soup fortune moving to
Ireland and we had the head of a light
signal CEO leave former CEO I guess that
by that point eight went left La Jolla
California and he moved to to the
Bahamas to an exclusive gated community
known as Lyford Key and I went and
knocked on his door and tried to meet
with him but he wasn't interested in
talking to me but but these folks some
of them actually tried to get
legislation passed which is what caught
our interest
they hired a former member of Congress
of course and they drafted special
legislation so that they could
expatriate they could renounce their
citizenship and not owe any taxes but
then they could still live in the u.s.
basically and fortunately that that
legislation didn't make it and in fact
Congress enacted a law to
to prevent folks from doing this kind of
thing except they don't enforce the law
no and people can come and go as much as
they want the fellow the allied signal
CEO today has a house in Aspen Colorado
and he comes and goes as and he actually
these stories um he actually he actually
created an Center for entrepreneurial
ism at the University of Maryland in his
name and he visits the University of
Maryland campus frequently this is a guy
who basically left the country and
doesn't pay taxes here anymore but he
talks about what a wonderful experience
he had as a businessman in the u.s. I
mean is it this the story is full of
audacious hoots pot I mean like you have
never seen before and and they do it all
with a straight face so anyway I don't
know if we should do questions or we
could talk for hours but I sure it's a
great question the the two things the
most consumer oriented thing is if you
hear a deal that sounds too good to be
true
there's a fairly good chance it is to go
be true there there is an awful lot of
internet scam type stuff going on here
and you should be very even though we've
just presented a scenario that everyone
gets away with it in the IRS doesn't
enforce it I don't know if you're like
me if the one time in my life I would
attempt something like that I but the
IRS you know just and I'm sure that
we'll all be audited and at this point
anyway but but they basically you know
you're if you're a poor or middle class
you're more likely to be audited frankly
than if you have all these fancy
offshore trusts and shelters and there
are statistics that bear out what I just
said so so good luck trying to do that
so I one thing is to be the old buyer
beware consumer beer where taxpayer
beware the other issue is a larger issue
and you know politicians pander to the
public on every subject imaginable one
of the things they do is about taxes and
we don't take positions on legislation
this book has we wrote this book when
George Bush was still the governor of
Texas we had no idea what was going to
happen with the election this is really
case studies of how people avoid pain
evade and avoid their tax
but there is an issue here where we're
not enforcing the law for all people and
we talked about it this is not a
discussion you didn't hear gora Bush
talked about this in the presidential
campaign
you don't hear anyone on Capitol Hill
wringing their hands about how we've
gutted the enforcement staff by a third
and wealthy Americans don't pay very
much in taxes these days and and
thousands of them are not paying any
taxes you're not hearing any of this
discussion it's simply not on the agenda
that's a really interesting issue and as
citizens I think one useful thing of the
cheating of America is to tell the
American people that you better think a
little more closely about the whole tax
issue because there's there's a little
bit of a game going on here where we
don't really we don't really discuss not
enforcing the tax laws we just kill the
agency gradually over a period of years
and we got the employees by a third over
20 years while the number of tax payers
has risen by a third and and no one
discusses it it's all done in that
wonderful quiet nuance sophisticated
Washington way where no one discusses it
and then you wake up and you see the
numbers and that's that's the messages
there's more going on about your taxes
than you realized and I think as
citizens we need to know that and it
need to be a little bit more informed so
this is a personal message here and
there's a societal democracy about who
who pays the freight in our culture who
benefits and and how fair is it all and
and I have to say that is an element you
come away with scratching your head
other questions yeah the public if we
went to sort of a flat tax structure
- this humor based tax um you know
people
stealing and basically finance for those
who didn't hear the question should we
go to a flat tax or some sort of
consumer tax so there have been
discussions about everything from a
national sales tax to a flat tax we
don't take positions on on taxes or what
the best tax is I mean the purpose of
the book was really to expose all these
people and what they're up to are and if
we tell you a precise thing that
everyone will say this book there's a
brief that we're just it's our agenda is
to bring about a this kind of tax with
that kind of tax but I will mention a
quick story back in 1996 Steve Forbes
when he was running for president was
talking about the flat tax and being the
pain in the neck that we are at the
Center for Public Integrity we decided
it would be interesting to talk to a CPA
about how much a flat tax would affect
Steve Forbes and so we gave all of his
financial information to a CPA and we
found that the flat tax would cut
Steve's taxes in half and so I'm not an
economist and I'm not a tax expert even
despite this experience but I'm a little
skeptical about the flat tax for that
reason one other thing about the flat
tax is that a lot of the a lot of things
we found in doing the book I mean the
Internal Revenue Code we called the IRS
said how many pages are in it and the
the guy laughed and said it's a
ridiculous question there is no
definitive edition of the of the code
you know we talked about having a rule
of law and transparency and and
everybody knowing what they're supposed
to do and there's not even a definitive
edition of the tax code but it is about
in some editions 17,000 pages and most
of that is dealing with defining I mean
they're do bothers if there's an awful
lot in there but a lot of it is defining
income and and nobody you know what is
income if you know we treat it in so
many different ways stock options aren't
treated the same way as salary which
aren't treated the same way as deferred
compensation which are not treated the
same way as dividends which aren't
treated the same way and the list is
virtually endless
in part that's a reflection of how
complicated as a society we've become
but I think with the flat tax I don't
see how it's any simpler if you still
have to define what income is and and
you know one of the and I don't know
that it necessarily ends cheating if
somebody can convert all of their income
to options or assets or you know things
that the corporation will pass to them
value in that way you know I mean I
think all of a sudden you'd have a lot
of people with no salary and an awful
lot of so and and with the national
sales tax and the only thing that I came
across an article somewhere where
somebody pointed out that I mean if you
if you think that that's if you think
about the way Washington works and
lobbying and things like that so we're
gonna pass a national sales tax suddenly
got the dairy producers saying well we
can't have a tax on milk it's for the
children I mean bones and teeth and the
next thing you know the the cereal
manufacturers come along and say yeah
but you know they've got to have
something to pour the milk on why are we
taxing cereal and before you know it
you've got you know the cigarette
manufacturers the beer manage the
distillers you know and everybody else
saying well our products should be
exempt till and so you'd end up I mean
you know what kind of tax base you'd end
up with is you know so there are
problems with all of the minutes and
this is why we have a 17,000 page long
tax code because it's so hard to come up
with a perfect system but I think
there's a quote in the book by Abraham
Lincoln which is that and I'm gonna
terribly paraphrase it but he says more
or less it if we wait until we come up
with the perfect system whereby
everybody will pay exactly according to
his means we'll never tax anyone at all
and you know that's kind of that's kind
of the nature of the beast and you know
we I guess we have to do the best we can
with it I mean one of the frustrations
is that those 17,000 pages are loaded
with thousands of pages of special deals
for special folks in Washington if you
have you know millions of dollars you
have not one law firm but three or four
of them and you you layer in
special deals for yourself and you have
a difference that a lawyer's helping you
every year not pay taxes after you've
done your own loophole and so when you
add that all up certain folks are
afforded certain benefits from the tax
code and others aren't and it may be
entirely legal
it may be avoidance because you helped
write the law and you then helped
exploit that law but the average citizen
doesn't have a clue what that is and
they don't want to spend $300 an hour or
$500 an hour or more finding out all
that stuff and so it's it's it's a it's
a tricky mess which the other thing that
the pervasiveness one idea we thought
about calling this book The Millionaire
Next Door might be a tax cheetah is a
the extraordinary extent to which there
are thousands of folks and that that's
what most amazed me this is not one or
two rogue characters out there and that
that still is the most stunning thing to
me is the extent of it other questions
yeah focus on
sure the question was how did we decide
which folks to focus on builder you want
to take a crack at that we had weekly
meetings for three years that's one
issue but do you want you take it from
there about how we to begin with you
begin with a very limited set of people
because it's it's basically people who
for the most part had cases in US Tax
Court you know where they had gone
through and the records were available I
mean because tax returns are secret
unless you have somebody and I guess
sometimes you can get him in divorce
cases we weren't as comfortable with
that because you know a lot of times if
those records are sealed so I mean
that's kind of hit-or-miss and so we
decided to focus on tax court and what
we basically looked for was boy this is
the fascinating process review we'd
start with statistics of income which is
the IRS you know tells you how much is
collected in taxes and who's paying what
and what deductions are used in etc etc
and then we looked through Tax Court
cases looking for examples of specific
instances where people were using these
kind of holes in the revenue net and so
that was that was an awful lot of the
cases and we look for the ones that were
statistically significant and then we
picked a few that were just you know
kind of outrageous like the you know the
the Ross case I think as an example we
knew that the IRS had how I forget how
many futures about a thousand fugitives
that they track and and Ross was one of
them he was on the list and you know we
I guess we were thinking of doing mark
rich but at the time we felt that he had
too much notoriety we're gonna do
somebody else we also write about it for
if you want some amusement there's a one
chapter in there about a the first legal
brothel in America a Mustang Ranch and
there are pretty hilarious issues about
cash receipts and various women making
two or three hundred thousand dollars a
year and not reporting that the earnings
and so the fellow who ran the Mustang
Ranch was a convicted of tax evasion and
so they shut the ranch down
and then they put it up for auction
public auction and this fella buys back
the Mustang Ranch under a dummy company
they operates it for a few years the IRS
doesn't know that it's still him running
the Mustang Ranch and then the feds
figure it out and they go after him
again and they flees the country today
he lives comfortably in Brazil he will
not be prosecuted and there's no
extradition treaty with Brazil and he's
sitting on millions of dollars in in
revenue another case of a the fish that
got away and the book is really kind of
loaded with a lot of these stories of
these kinds of folks but that one is
obviously we actually interviewed some
of the women and it's pretty funny the
IRS has a name for them informal
suppliers is that right other questions
yeah there must be some tax attorneys be
hearing of all of these or many of these
evasions and i wonder if you could talk
about some of the firm's and some of the
lawyers specifically that are mentioned
in the book oh the the question is what
attorneys by name the one attorney that
gets a lot of discussion is a fella
named Burton Kanter based in Chicago who
basically helped the Pritzker family
helped a lot of very famous families
avoid taxes for a number of years helped
make help the producer of One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest avoid taxes either we
give all the examples of the kinds of
clients this person had and we actually
did talk to him on on the phone and he
did consent to an interview but the IRS
has been tracking this guy I believe for
10 or 15 years at least or longer is
Jerome Schneider a lawyer I was not sure
what he is yeah yeah I don't think
there's one fella is sort of a an ex-con
who is teaching people how to avoid
their taxation was Portico okay he's a
hardened ex-cons or something but but we
actually do list some of the attorneys I
think the one we spoke about the most in
the book was burden Kanter right right
yes and he had a he was one of the more
inventive people he was involved in an
offshore bank in the 1970s and the I
think was in the voice embarrassing
account was in the Bahamas was a casul
Bank and Trust Company and in the 80s he
was involved in setting up cable vision
and designing all these partnerships it
allowed
Charles Dole and was the founder of this
company
and a lot of the investors through all
these partnerships to actually lose
money rather than make money from a very
successful business and and he's there
was a very long case I think the initial
IRS brief and it grants thousands of
pages and that they had years and years
of motions and finally they go through
the tax court trial process in which
there's just a judge who hears the
entire case and he sat down to sift the
evidence and he took five years to
render a decision after going through
all of these records and all of this
massive and and basically but I'm not
sure if it's going to be appealed or not
but basically found that Burton Kanter
probably should have paid more taxes and
then he actually did and his opinion was
480 pages or something 600
we looked at this case and it's just
mountains and mountains of paper and
that's just the filings I mean the
normal Tax Court case you know I mean
these these are pretty complicated
involve cases you may have like two or
three of the you know bankers boxes of
for legal documents that was I mean the
briefs of this was like the the the poor
clerks at the US tax court will Beall
this thing out with back strain and and
you sure you want to look at all this
and well this is the first set of papers
and so that was a that was always a
fascinating thing I mean the challenge
of writing this book more than any other
book the center is written was the
writing of the book because we had we're
not accountants and we're not lawyers
and we don't play them on television and
we thought it would be what no one
wanted to read a legal brief though you
had to make this come alive you know
this is about people and the games the
things people do basically is what this
books about it happens to be there doing
it with taxes but but we didn't want to
write a book an expose of the IRS that
wasn't the idea and it wasn't an idea to
tell you every in in and out of the tax
code it was the show people and what
they do and how they do it and and how
the system works or doesn't work in a
broad macro way and the drafting and the
redrafting and the redrafting and the
redrafting of making it about people and
and making it approachable and
accessible to the public was a big part
of the process more than our other work
other questions yeah some of these
people like Leona Helmsley and and Marc
rates are obviously household names by
now the other folks that you outed did
you find that they had had no media
coverage before or very little in the
American public was an outrage so it
didn't blossom or did you you know or
you've just totally outing people here
that maybe from from you know henceforth
will get more coverage meaning terms of
these companies that might have
shareholders I'm wondering if will there
be a reaction
that would be good if there's a reaction
now if if any of those companies are
listening no just in some cases the the
companies had been or that people have
been written about like when Joe Ross
fled Oklahoma that was a story in
Oklahoma obviously but a lot of these
I'm not sure some the answer is that
some were publicized to some extent some
were not publicized at all and we are
outing them for the first time you know
reporters don't generally congregate at
US Tax Court they don't generally report
on what's in those records and one of
the amazing achievements of beau else
and then the team is that they basically
lived in US tax court for two or three
years which to me is pretty
extraordinary by itself and so I would
say for the most part we're outing
people here these are corporations that
probably have never mentioned to their
shareholders the the games that they've
been playing they don't really want the
public to know the extent to which
they've done these things they don't you
know Merrill Lynch does not want the
world to know that they had an illegal
scheme
most of the Carnival Cruise Lines don't
want you to know that they're actually
registered offshore to avoid taxes and
Liberia and the Bahamas we name those
firms we tell you how much they saved in
taxes that this is this is a giant pain
in their backside this book and you know
I'm hoping they enjoy it yeah
anything conclusive answer I've seen a
few people who have ordered it on the
front desk but is that right yes but I
don't think I've heard directly from
anyone when we released the book the
other day at the National Press Club we
were shadowed by a tax advocacy group
that felt that we were unfairly beating
up on these poor folks so I mean they're
there there's people out there that are
doing all kinds of stuff there and yeah
we have heard from they weren't even in
the book I guess we shouldn't but we
actually haven't heard from any of these
the subjects of our stories we have not
heard from them we did try to reach all
of them and we interviewed a number of
them there were hundreds of interviews
all together in this book so you know
I'm hoping we hear from them in the
coming weeks that would be an
interesting conversation yeah
pose if you're offered free free cruise
tickets you might not want to go join me
in thanking Charles Lewis bill Allison
and I know would be happy to design
copies of your book speak to you
privately as well thank you thank you